foreign
comes out today and says Americans are
falling behind on car payments at a
higher rate than anytime three times as
bad as 2009. well I wonder why recession
I wonder why Dave
because people are taking these notes it
says there's a growing cohort of
Americans facing Auto repossessions this
is an ominous sign for the U.S economy
during the pandemic a surge in you used
car prices
forced yes
to take out bigger loans and that right
there forced yep you were forced that's
the word you didn't have a choice well
here's the thing on that that I mean you
had to have a 74 000 Raptor and so you
were forced and that's what I saw Dave
if you look at
people are saying what's your choice
what was our choice choice is don't be
stupid that's your choice that's your
choice don't be stupid try not being
stupid that's a good choice and then and
then the the other side of it the other
side of reality like you said the people
who chose to go against the grain are
saying hey you know I just bought a car
in cash that I could afford it's getting
me from point A to point B and when the
right time comes I upgrade so there
there is a cohort of Americans who do
have the right idea Dave there's there's
some smart people there are some people
there's some stupid people yeah there's
a lot of stupid people Dave 85 percent
of Americans have car notes eight and of
those 85 percent of Americans
15 of them have a car note of a thousand
dollars or more it's just hard to wrap
one thousand
I just can't even get my head around
that
so here's the thing if you put that as
Jade did in a calculator and talked
about it last week and that piece that
went viral if you invest a car payment
for just a couple decades you will have
over a million dollars you'll have five
million dollars if you do it for three
decades thank you and so I don't have
the money say for my kids Kyle it's just
cause you're stupid and you put all your
money in a car payment that's why you
got no money you were stupid and can you
talk to the people Dave because I try to
tell them I try to tell them I said I
said the same thing you said and you
know what they said to me where are you
getting a 10 rate of return who's going
to invest their money over 30 years Jade
and you want to know what the answer is
millionaires millionaires that's how
people make their money if you're
listening and you don't understand that
this is not a car problem this is a YOLO
problem you only live once
oh you sweet little child listen adults
devise a plan and follow it children do
what feels good Bingo very few people
who are successful are whiners
they don't walk around with a big V on
their forehead that says victim I'm
sorry I can't get it I want a car that's
safe oh shut up they roll up their
sleeves and they work seriously there's
people here who roll up their sleeves
and work there are actual people in the
world who will set aside a portion of
their income for 20 30 years and invest
it into their 401K into their IRA and
they become millionaires that's what we
call them we hear them every day on the
air so for all of those people they
weren't forced to do that they weren't
forced but for all of these folks out
here yakity yakin talking Yak talk about
oh you can't get a 10 rate of return
where here's what I kept hearing what
stocks give you an annual rate of 10
return the stock market has averaged
11.8 percent since it began hello and if
David 500 that's the average on it since
it began average for for 80 years you
dumb butt but this is not hard we're
sitting here telling you you got Dave
Ramsey who's got more money than anybody
you know and then Forbes Magazine tells
us the number one payment keeping people
broke is their car note it's not just us
so if you want to think it's just oh
it's just Ramsey Solutions they're the
only one they're the only folks out here
saying this that is not the case the
case is 85 percent of people have
Carnival here's the thing 67 percent of
people are living
and work
what a concept what you'll have is is
the ability to sacrifice to win see
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good here's the
thing so when I went broke
we lost everything
we had one car with a payment on it
re I I reaffirmed it out of bankruptcy
and I'm paying my paying my payment
paying my paying my payment
and my wife would have left but we only
had one car
and so I mean we were we were we're mad
we were hurt we were wounded
whining like some of you people are
and a guy loaned me a car because I
refused to I that's it I'm not borrowing
any more money he loaned me a 1978
Cadillac with 478 000 actual miles
aren't the predominant color on it was
Bondo
the vinyl roof was torn loose across the
front so when you drove it it filled up
with air looked like a parachute
I'm driving a Bondo buggy with a
parachute on top now you know what I was
driving before that before I went broke
a jaguar
I went from Jaguar to parachute Bondo
buggy because you know what happens when
you go broke you don't care what other
people think they don't care
I lost my need to impress your butt at a
stoplight
and so I go into a nice neighborhood and
that car the cops are following me think
I'm there to rob somebody and so I got
profiled based on my car can you imagine
that I can and so uh you know so I'm
I drove like no one else and I saved up
and I paid cash for a thousand dollar
car which is an incredible upgrade and
gave my buddy his Blessing back that he
had loaned me
and then we move on to the next one
right and we save up and we buy a three
thousand dollar car and we save up and
we buy a ten thousand dollar car you
know I drove like no one else so now I
drive anything I freaking want Come On
Come On Dave seriously y'all need to
know what it feels like to work
and stop your whining it's not becoming
the wussification of America the things
you think you have to have to survive is
sickening it's sickening for a short
period of time pay a price to win no one
wins without paying a price
the repo rate on you idiots right now is
three times what it was in 2009 in the
Great Recession it's the worst repo rate
we've seen in 30 years stop it